The researcher sent me a very
wonderful microscopic picture
of these microneedles.
And he really wanted
to try to get a cover.
And although this course is
about a camera and a lens,
I thought it'd be
interesting for you
to see the possibility of
creating a potential cover
submission from a
horizontal picture.
So here is the
picture that he made.
And what I decided to do
was -- I was thinking ahead
and cropped it, imagining what
the image would look like,
becoming a vertical shot.
There I did crop it.
And then what we have
to do is make sure
when we're looking for a
cover to make the DPI setting
right, which is 300 DPI.
The width of the
image needs to be 8.5.
And we have to increase
the canvas size to make
the vertical dimension 11.
I then selected a
piece of the background
and distorted it to make
up for the empty space.
And you can see that
I made a mistake,
and I needed to fill in the side
that I didn't get a hold of.
Eventually I really do
encourage you to consider
doing these kinds of things.
We're not changing
the microneedles.
We're just changing the
background of the microneedles.